[Music]
l.a county reinstates the mask mandate
for lax public transport and uber rides
[Laughter]
yeah dude so as much as like the rest of
the nation is like
having these like no more mask laws and
stuff ellie county is backstepping and
reinstating it what the [ __ ] dude wear
one today yeah it's effective day so
where do you have to wear county really
yeah
and well
well businesses are allowed to choose
whether or not they want to still have
math okay but the places where it's un
like
no question you got to wear it lax
public transport
and ubers too oh so they turned it back
on so it's kind of the same stuff that
was before but then it's like mandatory
for those so man i hated going on ubers
and wearing masks
because some ubers i don't know how you
guys are but like some uber drivers are
kind of like stop and go and i get
nauseous already but then when it have
something on my face i feel even more
nice i get dizzier quicker so i actually
like it when i can open the window a
little bit then i don't i don't really
mind i just have fresh air
man i thought of inventing a mask made
out of pantyhose so that you could just
completely breathe but technically have
a mask on but somebody beat me to it
dude i saw a lady wear a mask but it was
just a fishnet like stalking thing
and it said like no mask or some [ __ ] so
she was like protesting
yeah but it was like a map yeah yeah
that's fire my favorite was when they
started coming with the boba mess so you
could have a hole for boba but with
straws
you could put it back up that is science
you can still comply and have bobo about
gyms do they gotta have a dinner it's
down to that thing where they said
businesses are allowed to choose so if
that gym just happens to be you know pro
mask then everyone in there has got to
put it on you remember we were training
with masks hitting each other masculine
that was tough oh yeah that's hard
enough with headgear that's a massive
user gyms have uh masks on and i'm like
wow hey what are you guys doing it's so
hard man just either put it on or you're
gonna get covered by grappling with them
the mess is good it stops ringworm too
yeah that's true it does stop ringworm i
did hear that you rub it on your body
afterwards if you're that [ __ ] close
with someone even with a mask you're
going to get covet so why the [ __ ] are
you having it on
you get everything
[Laughter]
else the whole thing all the above yeah
something else you can get [ __ ]
herpes too damn it is what others cities
are doing dumb [ __ ] like this
what about new york well la county that
is the thing right now i'm for sure i'm
not going to fly out of lax
for a long time then john wayne it is i
got so many other airports i could
choose from now name them go
burbank
mccarron dude oh yeah that's pretty fire
or the hair it's called harry reid now i
think they changed it really yeah they
changed my private the vegans yeah this
guy flies private jets dude
no i'm a no business class doesn't allow
a massage so you're gonna have to fly
into lax
i'm gonna fly
fly into harry reid too
vegas one
oh so in new york it's kind of the same
thing where they rolled back on the they
they really easy today huh
yeah they eased up and this is like from
two days ago but they said you still
have to wear um
oh wait the federal government no longer
requires masks to be worn on planes
trains and other forms of public
transportation but in new york city mass
are so acquired on the subway and buses
what i found out is how the jurisdiction
works is federal law is actually the
loosest
and then because i thought like oh if
it's federal everyone abides by it but
it's actually the way the states are
structured as federal law is the loosest
and then states have higher jurisdiction
and then counties have higher
jurisdiction and then cities have the
highest jurisdiction oh okay so that's
what so that's why like uh like let's
say federally you don't need to have a
mask and like let's say even state you
don't have to have a mask let's say even
county you don't have to have a mass but
like let's say if garcetti was like for
la i want to have a mask then all of l.a
right unless federal kicks in and they
decide to harp down on everybody yeah
but they usually don't they usually
respect um yeah they respect how they
want to run see that's important to know
right because that's how you figure out
who you listen to or at least like what
the guideline is well that's why a lot
of people were like why can't america
get it together and i'm like it's
because we're more like a collection of
countries yeah it's like the states have
way more power than the federal
government's the way that it's
structured and it's the the states have
a culture of their own so like some
states like florida right after lockdown
they're just like you know what we ain't
doing this we're just gonna stay open
[ __ ] yeah and the federal government
couldn't control that
and in other states complied completely
with what the federal standards were so
it's like
it's it's all over the place because the
states and not only the states like you
know like bart said the cities have the
most power so la county could be one way
where sacramento could be completely
different
it's kind of it's kind of within the
same state yeah federally like weeds
legal but some states are like no it's
still illegal or federally ar 15s are
completely legal but some states are
like no it's illegal
so it's just a big like mismatch and
it's also like the mass thing especially
is just down in enforceability
you know like if you just get into uber
and the driver just goes i don't really
give a [ __ ] that's as far as that goes
yeah you know it's all enforceable i've
been in one during the pandemic where i
literally don't know where it was and i
was like i'm so sorry sir i don't i
think i fell in my pocket i don't have
one i can keep my face covered the whole
time or you just refused me and he was
super cool he's like nah let's go let's
jump in man
i think it's mostly i went into one and
he was like this
so um i got he used mine
i got into a i got into his cab and he
goes your name is joseph my name is
yusuf same name
and then he had his mask like this yeah
and then he had this windows down and he
was just talking to me like this the
whole time
and then they said but it was freaking
puts on your back he had his mask on
like this the whole [ __ ] time he's
like do you want to cover it do you want
a
snicker
you have the bubble hole
so you got to have your mask on but it
didn't say where yeah remember the thing
that uh when we were playing craps in
vegas and then there was that guy who
like joined the table and um his mask he
just kept like slowly putting it down
and they would always be like sir you
got to put your mask on he kept delaying
the game sir you got to put your mask on
sir again you have to put your mask on
then he started winning hell of money
and they just stopped telling it
yeah he started like like playing way
more and putting more down and then his
[ __ ] was like down to here and they
didn't say sagging yeah the pit boss
stopped carrying he was just like cool
that guy won a lot of money the people
that i
feel
the people that feel the worst for are
uh like servers that have long shifts
dude for right certain jobs require the
employees to still wear it like coffee
shops too yeah and they but they're
there for like eight hours and they have
to wear it the whole time where the
patrons don't even have to anymore i'm
like man i feel so bad i do feel bad for
them yeah i feel bad too that sucks
makes their face break out and stuff
seriously yeah it's already been proven
that it's like complete [ __ ] right
and then i don't know why that they
continue to do this [ __ ] when
i don't know man there's already so much
that came out about it what's crazy is
the backtracking thing was supposed to
be a joke you know like oh imagine we go
back to it and it actually happened
right actually holy [ __ ] it really is
gonna happen that's crazy right isn't it
coming back china is like back on
lockdown and stuff shanghai is going
some crazy [ __ ] vicious lockdown there's
covet camps and they're running out of
food and [ __ ] and like
yeah so there's a possibility they might
come back here who knows i don't i can't
i don't know what to expect anymore yeah
seriously just be ready for it all this
is the first time in my life i've
actually believed in conspiracy theories
i was like does this stuff might
actually happen well the more they might
yeah the more the media and the
government just tells you well don't
even think about that is when you're
like i should probably think about that
how they're like don't even talk to each
other about whether or not this is as
bad as it is what's
what i'm saying though is like okay so
several years ago right a lot of the
stuff that like we would mention here
people be like oh my god that's
ludicrous that's so [ __ ] crazy the
same [ __ ] that probably said
that now are believing all the stuff
that we [ __ ] talked about because
it's like we just said it early when
you're too early about something and
there is no pandemic or people don't
question the government they just go
man just believe everything we hear on
cnn and then everything just i think
went
really in your face during the pandemic
when people were just questioning a lot
of [ __ ] well that's the crazy thing is
even if you are the person that believes
everything on cnn if you graft it out on
what they've said and how much they
flip-flop from left to right back to
front then which one are you believing
like well i think they're like goldfish
where they just watch whatever today's
thing is forgot what they said before
yeah because i'm like how can you watch
this contradictory [ __ ] and
completely forget that they actually
told us that if we get vaccinated we
can't get covered these craziest parts
specifically all the news agencies said
that the craziest part is i think that i
saw was when i saw these two clips cut
together i think i from like the 80s or
90s but kamala called biden like a
racist bigot and all this stuff and
they're like his vp
when she was the one that got chosen and
she was like this is such an honor i'm
like what the [ __ ]
like
he's smelling tanks man
super politics politics dude right
complete [ __ ] utter [ __ ]
i know isn't it wasn't it that like
kamala or biden was responsible for like
maybe this kamala was responsible for
like the uh prosecution of like weed
well yeah she she her her laws
incarcerated more and created more
damage to the black community
and she's running on this whole [ __ ]
about like yeah like women and
minorities but it's like you they're in
there because of you yeah
tulsi called her out on that during the
primaries and [ __ ] no response nothing
dude i was like
it's just wild how it all works no one
cares about you know the the policy
making and all the issues that they've
created they just want an image of it
it's just the image it's like hey we are
this and you know these are the people
and it's like i don't know man to me
that's a wolf in sheep's clothing you
know i think she's very likable that's
what i think i think she's very likeable
you hear her talk long enough she has a
good laugh
yeah she'll laugh anything off that one
clip first saying joe we did it
that's all i know of her
and then the other the other clip is
don't come that's the other clip those
are the two clips i've seen and i don't
think any of those politicians work for
us like all of them don't give a [ __ ]
no none of them give them oh they're all
working for corporations and whatever
the [ __ ] well they have such large like
goals that are that we're just like the
tiniest little details
none of them care about us right but my
girl pelosi though
you know i love her trey vaughn love
copying her uh stocking she's well she
made 100 mil bro she's about to visit
taiwan right now and china's like well
taiwan will
receive some major consequences if she
does really
just for her going i guess they don't
want any u.s people recognizing taiwan
as a country or whatever it is so she
was like i'm going to taiwan and then
china was like you mean china
and she was like
maybe
anyway
i don't get it
[Music]
do